Найкраще Азіз почуває себе, коли залишається наодинці зі своїм стадом.
зверху, він нікому не повинен пояснювати,
чому він народився дівчинкою і називався раніше Азізе.
Тут вівчар може бути просто таким, яким він є.
Інколи мені подобається бути серед людей.
Але дуже часто я хочу бути просто на самоті.
І тоді мені знову всього забагато.
Я повинен заспокоїтися, і найкраще тут, в угрі.
Азіз живе у селі Чікрік, неподалік від сирійського кордону.
Одна турецька газета назвала його проклятим,
адже лише у цьому селі живе більше двадцяти інтерсексуалів -
людей без однозначної статі.
Таких як зараз уже 50-річний Азіз.
У нього немає чітко виражених зовнішніх статевих органів
тому він ще й до сьогодні має носити при собі рожеве посвідчення, як жінка.
При цьому ще дитиною він усвідомлював, що не хоче бути дівчиною.
Одного разу коли я побився з одним хлопцем,
він потягнув мене за моє довге волосся і кинув об землю.
Після чого я побіг додому і волосся обрізав.
Я був сповнений ненависті до себе і свого оточення.
А через посвідчення я ще й досі страждаю.
У цій віддаленій частині Туреччини усе ще прийнято одружуватись із родичами.
У дуже бідному Чікріку всі між собою родичі.
Тому швидко поширюються спадкові хвороби. Також і інтерсексуальність.
Також і цей 21-річний хлопець,
який не хоче, щоб його упізнали, є інтерсексуалом.
Він зробив операцію тому, що хотів мати чоловічі статеві органи.
Мені довелося пережити три операції.
Кожна операція коштувала у перерахунку 500 євро.
Для мене це половина річного заробітку.
Зате тепер я знову почуваю себе повноцінним.
Зрештою, я хочу одружитися і мати дітей.
Після операції мало інтерсексуалів здатні мати потомство.
Для цих чоловіків із сусіднього села це також нічого б не змінило.
Вони були б проти якби хтось із їхньої сім'ї одружився б з інтерсексуалом.
Вони народжуються дівчатами, а потім роблять із себе чоловіка.
І хто знає, можливо потім вони подумають про це знову інакше.
Наскільки мені відомо, вони не можуть мати дітей.
Вони, можна сказати, є геями.
Азіз ніколи не піддавав себе операції.
Зазвичай йому бракувало грошей.
До сусіднього великого міста Діарбакір він їздить не часто.
В крайньому випадку - до лікаря.
Цього дня він ще раз шукає поради у психолога Тугби Юксель.
Як почуваєтесь?
Знову погано. Я людина, яка хоче любити.
Але я хочу також, щоб любили і мене.
Коли бракує любові, мені стає погано.
Сім'ї, які приходять до мене, перенапружені.
Чи повинні вони виховувати свою інтерсексуальну дитину як дівчинку,
чи як хлопчика?. Вони вирощували свою дитину до п'яти років життя,
як хлопчика, який грає у футбол,
а потім він повинен раптом стати дівчинкою.
У цьому суворо консервативному суспільстві користі для Азіза мало.
Через те він завжди відчував себе чоловіком.
Щоразу, коли він закохувався, він розчаровувався.
У молодості я мав любовні стосунки з однією дівчиною з села, звичайно, таємно.
Але коли це випливало назовні, трапився величезний скандал,
і моя мрія луснула.
Тут головну роль відіграє суспільство.
Вона одружилася потім з іншим чоловіком.
Але Азіз ще не здався. Він хоче купити собі дешевий смартфон
тому, що чув, що в інтернеті можна легко познайомитися із жінками.
У крамниці, де продають телефони він просить показати,
як можна сфотографувати самого себе.
Фотографія потрібна йому, щоб створити профіль.
Коли він повертається додому, то знову трохи впевненіший.
Він ділить маленький будинок зі своєю матір'ю та десятьма іншими родичами.
Мати рада, що багато років тому Азіз вирішив бути чоловіком.
Чоловіка у нашому суспільстві цінують більше.
Дівчина одружується і йде.
Але чоловіки можуть забезпечувати сім'ї і успадковувати усе.
Тож Азіз сподівається, що колись за межами його села
знайдеться жінка, якій не буде заважати його минуле.
На свій новий телефон він записує пісню про кохання.
Незабаром він виставить її в інтернет.